We Begin this hour with one woman's
mission to help save a crucial part of
American culture grace young is an
award-winning cookbook author and
culinary historian her work on the
versatility and cultural significance of
the Chinese walk has earned her the
nickname walk therapist lately she's
helped Chinatown neighborhoods try to
get back on their feet since the
pandemic chinatowns in Philadelphia and
cities like Seattle are both considered
endangered now she met up with our Adam
Yamaguchi in New York City's Chinatown
to talk about the importance of these
communities and gave adam a walk therapy
session of his own
I always have to hide my Walks from my
husband because I have too many walks
are you going to tell us how many walks
no no I can't disclose that
Rhys young is a workaholic I have him in
my kitchen cabinet I have them in a
storage area somewhere in the apartment
that I will not disclose I have about
four in here wow yeah Young's Journey to
the walk began with French and American
Cooking inspired by watching Julia Child
as a kid
she took cooking classes and worked as a
test kitchen director for Time Life
books but never went to culinary school
Young's quest to Master Wok cooking
eventually led her to Hong Kong and to
Mainland China then back home to San
Francisco for some culinary
homeschooling in Cantonese cooking my
family's Cantonese when a stir fry is
really like done perfectly they say it
has walk hay which translates to walk
breath there is an Essence there's a
extra kind of smoky flavor that the food
possesses that breath helps steer the
food which helps develop flavors and
crisp texture what makes it so special
or different there is no other pan out
there that can steam boil poach
stir fry pan fry d-fat fry braise smoke
but it turns out just because something
may look like a wok doesn't mean it is
one now don't judge
this is my walk oh oh my goodness
this is a walk wannabe look at my walk I
don't want to be mine and yours young
says the best Wok to cook with at home
is 14 inches flat bottomed and made of
carbon steel the Box said it was a wok I
doubt if you can really get a nice sear
and Browning because it's too crowded
you've been in my kitchen I'm a walk
therapist once you get the right kind of
walk
elbow Grace elbow Grace this is intense
the real work begins
seasoning the pan and developing a
coating called a patina
every single time you cook with the wok
the pores of the metal are opening and
that oil is coating it and literally
burning into the wok and what happens is
polymerization and that patina is your
natural non-stick coating we make tomato
beef a special recipe she learned from
her parents and published in her first
book The Wisdom of the Chinese Kitchen
just like my parents used to remember
the traditional Chinese cooking vessel
is more than just cookware her family's
walk is now memorialized at the American
History Museum in DC it is a piece of
History it's getting the message out
though about the importance of
the role of the Walk yes and how
Traditions get lost in this country
[Music]
another tradition young couldn't see
fade America's chinatowns
during the pandemic she documented the
hardships the coronavirus dealt to Asian
businesses Amplified by The Surge of
anti-asian hate that traumatized the
community from Honolulu to New York
they're all struggling all of them
report less foot traffic even now post
pandemic oh yeah
pop Lee a nearly 50 year old institution
in New York's Chinatown shuttered its
doors during covid-19 and was on the
brink of closing for good three years
later co-owner Johnny muy says business
is just now picking up we can see the
really deep big different people waiting
to sit down she's a little bit of a
celebrity around here yeah what is she
doing for Chinatown he's helped me a lot
Grace
such my angel young has provided nearly
150 thousand dollars for chinatowns
across the country you know I know you
said that things aren't back yet but it
must warm your heart to see people
starting to
line the streets again absolutely and I
really believe Chinatown will come back
but it won't come back unless everyone
shows up
for young the stakes are more than just
about the walk but about preserving the
history and traditions that have formed
the very uniquely American patina
[Music]
CBS mornings Adam Yamaguchi New York
everything you just heard about the walk
is true I have one I love it Gail used
to have one and I think Nate and I have
concluded that she now uses it to hold
her takeout menus that's right that's
right and I have a sense of Pride
knowing that the walk that we have Tony
will make grace young very proud okay